deux autres invités à présent oui donc
nous recevons ce soir christine viron
vous êtes professeur de français au
collège sainte-thérèse au mesnil saint
denis et nous recevons également etienne
mirabel qui est élève au collège
sainte-thérèse donc vous venez ce soir
nous parler d'un projet assez original
donc vous vous travaillez au sein d'une
classe dont qui s'appelle la classe la
quatrième deux projets quatrième à
projets à quatrième à projets de quoi
s'agit-il de quel projet s'agit-il
exactement
mais c'est une classe qui a été fondée
il y a deux ans sur comment dire là
l'idée de notre chef d'établissement et
qui avait comme perspective d'offrir à
des enfants qui étaient essoufflés par
des rythmes scolaires effréné et qui
était en échec scolaire de leur donner
la possibilité de reprendre confiance en
eux car beaucoup d'enfants étaient en
mai estime d'eux-mêmes donc de leur
redonner confiance et à travers un
projet original mené par un
professionnel de théâtre guillaume de
moura qui est directeur de la compagnie
l'air de rien pour donner confiance à
ses enfants autour d'une oeuvre
littéraire
voilà alors cette oeuvre littéraire
cette année vous avez choisi germinal
oui et pourquoi ce choix
alors j'irai il ya une raison purement
pédagogique puisque germinal fait partie
des nouveaux programmes de 4e on étudie
les romans réalistes du 19e siècle mais
aussi parce qu'il nous semble que ce
cette oeuvre résonne à beaucoup de
résonance actuelle dans cette période de
crise et surtout elle nous donnait la
possibilité
à toute équipe pédagogique d'apporter sa
pierre à l'édifice dans la compréhension
de l'oeuvre
c'est à dire que par exemple quelles que
soient nos matières bien sûr moi je suis
professeur de français alors on pense
naturellement que c'est une étude les
théâtrales est dévolue aux profs de
français mais par exemple pour vous
donner quelques exemples le professeur
de musique a fait tout un travail sur
les orchestres métalliques parce qu'il y
avait beaucoup de bruit dans cette mine
donc ils travaillent sur des tôles sur
des dissonances des rythmes musicaux
très contemporain en physique ils ont
travaillé la combustion des gaz la vie
des mines fait ce projet a fédéré
finalement vêtements donc les
disciplines demandent de manière à ce
que les élèves puissent avoir accès au
travers de toute cette discipline
la thématique de base et qui est qui et
germinal instruments les élèves
on a pensé quoi pourquoi tu as intégré
cette formation qu'est ce que ça t'a
apporté bas 7 7 classes en
on devait s'engager signer un contrat
oui j'ai pardonné a même fait une lettre
de motivation on a je me suis allé dans
cette classe parce que je savais que
avec ce projet théâtre j'allais réussir
à prendre plus confiance en moi
et du coup à un mieux avancer dans ma
scolarité est oui alors en plus de ce
projet théâtre il ya quand même des
choses très concrètes aussi que vous
mettez en place puisque vous avez été
visité une mine
oui la mine où s'est déroulée en
l'occurrence aussi le tournage du film
de claude berri oui alors ok qu'est ce
que tu en as pensait de voir en vrai
aussi des situations peut-être kiki qui
illustrait parfaitement ce que les
répétitions
bah je me suis dit que c'était bien
parce qu'on pouvait travailler vraiment
dans des corps nus il y aura une
représentation je suis désolé on va
devoir interrompre on était très très
chargé sur l'actualité aujourd'hui merci
vous reviendrai sur le plateau pour nous
parler de vos actualités on vous le
promet j'espère que vous pourrez
répondre à notre invitation merci
aurélia pour la chronique culture c'est
la fin de cette édition du 7 8 je vous
souhaite une excellente soirée